online credit room nome banane e la city
ragazza è benvenuto che sono video sono
parigi oggi giochiamo al collo beauty no
no no no ragazzi oggi questo è il summit
your friends quindi golf with ciccio
ciao e c'è anche pietro come aveva
coraggio allora allora lo ammettiamo di
un contratto che tuina massimo risulti
settimanale ok è un gioco molto easy
dov'è presente bisogna buttare la marina
nella buca
vince chi fa buche in meno tiri
ovviamente quindi vinco io
niente devi trascina allora ci aspetta
che la guerra che bella farfalla
vorrebbe le textures esatto bra ufficio
al piano piano bravo così ufficio allora
in sei tiri marciano milano a fare un po
meno io è pietro invece ci equivaliamo e
così fa sta roba qua bravissimo all in
one
io ho fatto in un altro piano cxxo dai
pietro ma non era entrata vabbè 10 tiri
chigi come si deduce vasto rogo ma ho
capito che tu debba centrare il buchino
li provo non l'ho centrato bocchino e
mamma aspetta
no no è bravo ciccio a pietro davvero
che un po di caldo non ha capito ma se
lo scarso che stanno fatta veramente in
20 tiri festivo vai o meno male anche
pietro non è come me è un fratello non
ci aiuta ma ora che abbiamo fatto uguale
abbiamo fatto i punti sui quali finora
214 ma devi farla passare come i mezzi
mamma mia tua madre morta dai pietro la
bambina in sala parto non lo sappiamo ma
dai
carissimo siamo uguali pietro 2 sempre
uguali punticino
io poi una una una una non è vero la
vita è brutta perché dobbiamo continuare
a fare del prof regolari stesso
punteggio incredible è sempre ma no ho
sbagliato lo potrebbe esserci la
dipartita di pietro mario ha detto
pietro sono scazzo è poi tipo 2 e mezzo
come dai due e mezzo due come il mio
mezzo ai più può tirare sveglie questo
tirare le chiama aver fatto bravo e va
bene o no no no dietro mi ha staccato di
2 porca vacca no
[Musica]
è la voce delle pietre e chi lo faccio
in tre questo grande no in 23 mag
adesso la vita fa schifo recuperare tre
tiri a pietro questo è difficile ma
stiamo scherzando
ok no da ma perché la mia vita è brutta
l'ho fatta in tre perché dietro il 51
regola in tre
com'è fatta in cinque fatta in cinque ma
adesso comincio a trovare tranquillo
sbaglierò prima o poi non devi sbagliare
questa è una partita che io devo vincere
impegnava trasporto h
cinque punti di distacco razzi
recupererò te lo prometto
non c'entrano anche la videocamera in
stomaco bravo cicciole ok ok non la loro
seconda è preso to buono dai che all in
one go che curò cioè siamo già un tiro
recuperato basta così
prof e anch'io ho rifatto ma tu mica se
non mi fermavo a quello buono
non è vero ma dai
un altro tiro recuperata pietra
attenzione ai meno 3 si sente il fiato
sul collo
l'uomo comunque questa guerra ma farci
cioè non vorrei che la mappa barese più
facile
c'è veramente ma che schifo fatto no no
no posso rifarlo buono non ci credo
allora tutto il novizio io grande va
bene ok dai pietro sbaglia mi un po di
tiliqua sbaglio avere un pochettino
modale da ciechi e sorte storto
c'è una cosa che cantando bayern ha
sbagliato dai menu tiro in più o meno
ultimi più almeno tiro in più doveva
fare da quanto siamo detti addio
siamo pari non posso permettermi cagate
qua è difficile secondo la prima ci
prova dai ke skifo calare rumorista meno
uno meno 22 schifoso live ecco qua ti
voglio quest'estate for pact voluto cosa
ho visto bar cosa stavo ma è possibile
ora di nicuolo rifai
non so come ho fatto a fare questa croce
questa è stata la mente in quel pazzo è
immischiato per rifarla bene a chi ha
comprato quei due die è un box
recuperato in quei due la portavo vista
partire di fuori furtiva
mi sa che l'ha presa bene tv di questo o
no con giove cos'è sta roba qua devi
fare centri tipo ii ma credo sia
impossibile se è vero ben fatto con
attenzione
oh mio dio non via ordinaria guarda che
lui è male tutti tutti e design ma nella
quale scalzo esca dai fatto che sul
lungo non posso solo pietro alfa milano
edifici no dai non è vero e devi farla
di rimbalzo forte ma è difficile
rimbalzo di qua e non ci credo daimaru
pulse nei vostri madrid effettivamente
niente adesso che per maggio al torna
indietro
mica se si ferma che ridere
questa è l'ultima buca e devi farla in
sei tiri meno di me non so come starò ma
non mi chiede ti spari piano c spari
piano è attiva la fortissima ormai note
sfiga l'ha fatta in tre come occhi altro
è che faccio un mezzo c'è vabbè dai a
mente ma le mete più difficile per forza
sei scemo prima buca tensione quasi
google in one per tutte quante toccateci
ceva impegnati per ragazzi deciso ma che
[Musica]
guarda quell'uomo lì che schifo che fa
la prova pago il ciccione il credibile
tensione all ira non è vero
te lo giuro prego amici si prova il
massimo tira non è buono hai peccato il
pesce 3 rifatta in uno come hai fatto
quei fatti 1 vedono soda tirate a titoli
come primo anno era un bar
lei è vita mente sbagliato tanti punti
che tutti vedevo primo tac tac tensione
attenzione
let's go bene almeno ci bravi e troppo
tiger woods no no come e in pendenza che
fisica ciccio viene superato da pietro
di un punto
dieci punti di distacco da pietro buono
abbiamo due buche rimanenti o questa
bellissima e l'ha subito rifatto il
masso c'è no tre mesi fa lo abbiamo per
come fa è uscito di buca l'ultima lei
tira una botta così non vedo dove va
[Musica]
sì mi sa che vede tirare al massimo
arca tavole difficile
[Musica]
no il tentacolo le tua madre mamma mia
cosa stiamo facendo
a questa qua ogni volta la facevo in
mille niente analisi o no dai che il tie
spiraglio di massa sbagliato mi sa che
pietro hanno sempre scusa ho visto il
tentacolo l'ha spedito non so dove va
bene abbiamo fatto 81 76 ora che non
siete stati distantissimi io 66 amici
miei
spero che il video vi sia piaciuto
questa era una pro vita normalissima
uguale a quella barca normale tuo
inconscio lama bronzo ma niente rosa con
tiro 10 amici ma non è a norma
[Musica]